es revivir lo más crudo de la Guerra el
centro de kiev volvió a hacer este lunes
objetivo de un bombardeo un ataque que
se extendió por horas y que es el
primero contra la capital desde que el
kremlin desistió en su intento de tomar
esta ciudad nos despertamos esta mañana
con este saludo por parte de nuestros
vecinos usted verá esto aquí y por toda
la ciudad
al menos otras seis ciudades también han
reportado tales bombardeos desde el VIP
a lo bestia hasta harkkin en pro y
saporiya en el este En esta última urbe
los bombardeos golpearon zonas
residenciales como esta para el
presidente de Ucrania el objetivo de
Moscú es claro pone para España quieren
pánico y caos quieren destruir nuestro
sistema de energía no tienen remedio el
segundo objetivo son las personas y esos
objetivos fueron elegidos especialmente
para causar el mayor daño posible el
presidente Vladimir Putin reconoció la
ofensiva aseguró que su respuesta a la
explosión que afectó este fin de semana
a un entre Rusia y la Península
anexionada de crimea se trata de un
ataque que kiev no ha reconocido pero sí
lo celebró Dame según los datos forenses
y de otros expertos así como la
información de inteligencia muestra que
la explosión del 8 de octubre fue un
ataque terrorista un ataque que tiene
como objetivo destruir la
infraestructura civil crítica rusa
Moscú también celebró haber golpeado
todos los objetivos designados este
lunes además con la promesa de Putin de
una respuesta dura si continúan los
ataques desde Ucrania